là aussi c'est l'agriculteur qui fait
ses propres pâte à partir de son blé du
miel local puisqu'il vient de
villiers-le-bâcle manger bio c'est bien
les manger bio et local c'est mieux
c'est ce que les prix de la vallée
épicerie participative a mis en place en
janvier dernier pour rassembler les
agriculteurs de la région
le but c'est de manger plus local
premièrement et de manger si c'est
possible plus bio donc l'idée c'est de
se fournir localement en produits qui
existent
alors quand ils existent parce qu'en
région parisienne tout n'existe pas mais
donc par exemple on travaille avec le
fournil de villiers le bâcle qui est ici
tout près qui nous font du pain bio
la particularité de l'épi de la vallée
c'est que étant donné que comme je
voulais dit la main d'oeuvre est fournie
par les adhérents les matériaux sont
issus de la récupération on ne met
aucune marge sur les produits donc le
prix que nous payons aux agriculteurs
aux anneaux fournisseurs divers et
variés c'est le prix que que nous
vendons à nos adhérents
pour information les produits qui
partent le plus ici à l'épicé la bière
le chocolat et le papier toilette une
adhésion à l'association à partir de 30
euros qui permet d'accéder à des
produits frais et locaux
une nouvelle alimentation qui séduit de
plus en plus les yvelinois et les
essonniens c'est quelque chose en fait
que les gens veulent maintenant ils
veulent manger différemment ils veulent
manger local davantage bio riz pâtes
confiture lessive une épicerie qui
contient entre 200 et 300 produits des
aliments que l'on peut trouver à l'épi
de la balle et sans passer par le
supermarché
on est cinq à la maison je fais
quasiment toutes mes courses à l'épi gcc
quasiment d'aller ailleurs
il manque des choses on n'a pas de
brosse à dents évidemment que je
continue d'aller dans le commerce
traditionnel pour les brosses à dents on
a du dentifrice en poudre mais bon il
fait pas l'unanimité à la maison il ya
évidemment des choses qui m'a envoyé 200
à 300 produits de base s'est pas
beaucoup mais moi je m'arrange il ya des
choses que je n'achète plus parce
qu'elles sont pas les pays et qu'elles
sont pas nécessaires un nouveau mode de
vie plus rustique qui fait participer
les différents acteurs de la région
des épis qui n'en finissent plus de
pousser